America is debating whether to stay in
Afghanistan after more than seventeen
years of war now it's an issue close to
home for the family of special optical
forces sergeant Eric Iman he was killed
in the deadliest attack last year on US
troops in Afghanistan
Iman served in the military for 21 years
most recently as a green beret assigned
to Fort Bragg among his many honors and
awards are three Bronze Star medals and
three purple hearts in an interview
you'll see only on CBS News evening news
anchor Jeff Glor spoke with him on his
widow without her husband's legacy last
August
sergeant first class Eric Eman left
North Carolina for Afghanistan
it was his seventh combat tour we all
went into this appointment thinking it
was going to be the last one and he'd
come home and get set up to retire on
November 27th his wife Allie heard
there'd been an attack it was just a
typical morning trying to get three kids
ready in the morning chaos I saw in the
news and I tried to rush the kids for a
minute and I stood there and I thought
it's like oh that's that's horrible but
nobody called me so Eric's okay so all
right come on girls later that afternoon
after she picked up the kids the
doorbell rang and I had opened the door
not even looking I and you just you know
there's not a whole lot of reasons
there'd be two uniformed soldiers
standing at the side of your door and I
just wanted them to say it like just
they have the things that they have to
say but I just just wanted them to say
it um my four-year-old saw the whole
thing what did she say she's just a
parent suck your thumb
Eric Emond had been killed by a roadside
bomb in Ghazni province Afghanistan he
was 39 years old it's later that night
when I had told them and I just wanted
to get it through to them that had it
like daddy daddy's dead something really
bad happened and finally I old
it said head looked at me and said he
said he was coming home Ali and her
three daughters ages seven four and one
were now a gold star family for military
spouses and children
it is a distinction they never hope to
bear for the Iman's it is also painfully
ironic back in 2009
Eric suffered a traumatic brain injury
after an RPG attack in Afghanistan while
he was recovering he and others
including his friend Dan Magoon started
an organization called mass Fallen
Heroes to help gold star families they
heard Eric that those families were
forgotten about when all the pomp and
circumstance dies down and the flag is
presented and Families go on and then a
year passes and it's on to the next
story it's on so next next issue I'd
like to begin by thanking each and every
one of you for attending our second
annual fallen heroes memorial gala for
the next eight years
Eric devoted so much of his life to his
country and gold star families his death
leaves behind a new one that's all we
told them is that daddy's a good guy if
good guys always win and we just lived
in this blissfully ignorant bubble of
daddy's gonna be fine and daddy's gonna
come home that's how we lived our life
whether he was home whether he was
deployed everything was centered around
him he knew the dangers he does
shielding them in me mess fallen heroes
has supported Ali and the girls every
step of the way
in May Eric's name will appear on the
country's first memorial for US troops
killed in Iraq and Afghanistan located
in his home state it's in downtown
Boston
Eric helped build it what do you want
people to know about Eric every choice
he made was for other people was for the
betterment of others whether it be his
family or his country I was able to meet
Marines that he served with
they would say to me he made me the
person I am and all I could say back was
was me too he was an incredible person
he couldn't have been a better man I
guess I just want people to know that
Jeff Glor joins us now he sounds like an
incredible man what yeah how can people
help families have fallen heroes go to
Mass Fallen Heroes this is a group that
their mission has changed now because
they lost their quarterback because but
that's what they try to do they try to
help all of these families not just an
ally in particular she wants to stay in
her home in North Carolina now she can
have to put the kids through college at
some point but it's everything it's it's
employment services if veterans families
need help it's legal services health
care education they try to fill those
holes wherever they can when that money
comes in so important I just think of
that four-year-old daughter sucking her
thumb and hearing that she lost her
father God knows wow that's gonna start
her with a one year old a four year old
and a 7 year old I was so appreciative
of Ally sharing her story about Eric's
life so we can all know we are very
thankful to her and spoke to her last
night and we're gonna continue to to
talk alright Jeff thank you sir thank
you thank you